rehe haben hier noch viel platz auch
wenn ganz nordfriesland vollgestellt ist
mit windrädern schon vor über 20 jahren
fing das an strom aus erneuerbaren
energien das hat die bauern ihr reich
gemacht
einer von ihnen
reinhard christiansen er produziert
wesentlich mehr strom als er verkaufen
kann den strom auch gerne abgeben an die
örtliche bevölkerung das ja auch ganz
konkret etwas hat davon gut landschaft
hat sich verändert wir haben auch ein
bisschen schattenwurf und ein bisschen
schade und so und aber wenn man dann
strom günstig bekommt von den anlagen
die in der nähe sind so rein dann hat
das doch was nicht
und zum teil passiert das auch schon
grüner strom für elektroautos sauberer
geht's nicht in nordfriesland wird die
nutzung von e autos subventionieren
die e mobilität hat mich schon oder hat
uns schon länger interessiert und wir
haben dann hier in der region ihr die
möglichkeit gehabt für einen relativ
günstigen preis diesen wagen zu lesen
und damit eben auch die möglichkeit zwei
drei jahre auszuprobieren wie das mit
der e-mobilität sich im alter verhält
und seitdem kommt er regelmäßig zu
dieser sogenannten schnellladestation
den wagen zuhause aus der steckdose zu
laden ist offenbar zu umständlich mit
der normalen geschwindigkeit es dauert
stunden also es gibt gar nicht deswegen
im juli schnellladestationen dann
schafft man es in einer guten halben
stunde dann ist es hinzukriegen aber
sonst nicht nirgendwo sonst in
deutschland gibt es pro einwohner so
viele elektroautos die in nordfriesland
auch windmüller reinhard christiansen
fährt einen einen tesla für 120000 euro
in drei sekunden auf 100
stundenkilometer
wenn die mühen drehen dann haben wir
immer grünstrom ihr im ganzen netz
geräuchert sich selber versorgen
wir haben die produktion von 300 also
wir müssen exportieren
und um das zu erreichen fährt er
regelmäßig nach berlin
großer empfang beim bundesverband für
erneuerbare energie der windmüller aus
nordfriesland ist hier bekannt wie ein
bunter hund
seit jahren schon wirbt er für leitungen
designen windstrom vom norden in den
süden deutschlands bringen
dahin wo die industrie sitzt und die
meisten menschen wohnen die süd flink
heißt das ding
die sollen ja den strom den wir an steht
weiter produzieren und auch offshore
produzieren
der muss ja nach süden und wir können
letztendlich 17 millionen einwohner
nachher mit stromversorgung und die hat
schlief gehorchen und hamburg nicht
windmüller die er haben in deutschland
großen einfluss jahrelang wurden die
erneuerbaren energien von der
bundesregierung mit milliarden
subventioniert um die sogenannte
energiewende zu erreichen weltweit
einzigartig solarzellen statt kohle vor
einem vierteljahrhundert war das eine
verwegene vision heute ist es realität
im dezember hat die windenergie erstmals
die braunkohle als wichtigste deutsche
stromquelle verdrängt aber das ziel
bleibt bis 2050 soll mehr als die hälfte
des gesamten bedarfs aus erneuerbaren
energien gedeckt werden
wir sind auf dem weg und wir können das
schaffen also und wir wollen das auch
und wir sind auch gerade die hier im
windmühlen investiert haben also die
sind bereit auch mal ein bisschen
risikokapital in die hand zu nehmen und
einfach zu machen
wir wollen zeigen dass es geht wird ja
hier und da schon gemacht und dann muss
er aber auch flächendeckend eingeführt
werden und dafür muss die windenergie in
den süden und der strom muss noch
stärker als antriebsquelle der autos
genutzt werden dann könnte es klappen
mit der energiewende in nordfriesland
haben sie es fast schon geschafft